rien de sanitaires dans se passe il faut
arrêter de parler de passes sanitaire
cette impasse de coercition à presse de
biocontrôle c'est les libertés de base
et libertés le pass sanitaires il va
distinguer sur des fondements purement
médicaux des français
[Musique]
moi ce qui me dérange avec la décision
du conseil constitutionnel concernant
pas sanitaire c'est premièrement qu'il
n'est pas considéré de certaines
obligations maximale de fait alors que
le premier ministre devant les sénateurs
a dit que le pass sanitaires avaient
pour objectif une incitation très forte
à la vaccination obliger les gens à
vacciner alors que ce vaccin n'est pas
obligatoire
là est une manipulation absolument
pernicieuse pousser les gens à se
vacciner en faisant croire qu'ils sont
volontaires alors qu'ils sont contraints
par des lois parce que ce pass sanitaire
c'est une obligation matinale c'est pas
autre chose
[Musique]
si le vaccin permettait d c'est vrai de
diminuer nettement les formes graves de
la maladie
elle n'empêche pas là la transmission
est donc ça valide de defacto le pasteur
pardon n'y aurait pas une vaccination
obligatoire dans toute légalité
au lieu d un système de nars que
représente le passé mystère
[Musique]